that's a pinch me moment where you go
wow Bruce Springsteen's calling me and
he's telling me I did a good job can I
be honest this talking to you right now
is the pinch me moment I know a lot of
people come on here and they're first
this is my first time speaking with you
but
um you're a huge reason why I wanted to
like get into quote-unquote media I've
been listening to you my mom's been
listening to you we've been listening
for like 20 years wow well thanks for
that that's awesome I know the original
key to Robin's song like
I know that I know the robin music
changed in 2010 like
[Music]
to that Brash horrible sounding whatever
can you play some trip can you play some
of the robin uh theme music for us the
old one from 95.
sounded like a very uh atmospheric yeah
and then in tooth up right when I went
to Berkeley in 2010 it became I'll never
I was pissing my parents with laughter
every game
foreign
[Music]
do you have a favorite whack Packer do
you go that deep do you have someone
that you love yeah
um I I like uh Jeff the drunk a lot yeah
a lot I think he means well uh yeah wait
a second uh Jeff you hear that big star
like Charlie puth loves you man how do
you like that you're his favorite
whackpacker thank you Jeff your voice is
cleared up over the years
he's so good on the air isn't he I know
look at him just reeling off those
comebacks Jeff and Marianne I liked Eric
a lot of rest in peace Eric the actor
yeah we all love them Eric there all
right Jeff wait I seize the moment thank
you bye-bye
um I mean you must be a big fan of Robin
singing also with uh all the different
vocal performances over the years
[Music]
no I I know every single one here's the
thing Robin you might go off Pitch
frequently but you're the the tone and
resonance in your voice is really good
so I could I could make I if I had your
vocal in a studio I could make you sound
good finally wow I've never heard that
before that's really nobody has ever
said that yeah yeah yeah it's good you
have a good resonance
thank you